Welcome to "Ear Biscuits,"
the podcast for two lifelong friends
talk about life for a long time.
I'm Link.
And I'm Rhett.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we are celebrating 10 years
of "Good Mythical Morning."
It's a show that we make
other than this show.
It's on a platform called YouTube.
Apparently we've been
making it on that platform
for 10 years, and last week we did
a celebration week on the show,
and we're capping that off
with a lengthy discussion.
Of retrospective.
Looking back
on the length of "Good Mythical Morning."
Ten years.
It's not just length.
Link.
What?
Could you not use length?
However, we have established
that your porn name would
be Length Neal, right?
Did we?
I don't know if we've
ever said that publicly,
but we discovered that at some point.
Well, how did you discover this, Rhett?
This is getting weird.
It was a conversation.
It was a conversation
amongst friends, I believe.
I don't know, maybe it was,
you probably know, it may have been
on "Good Mythical More."
I think it happened
at this table.
Really?
Length Neal
was born at this table?
I think so.
So, my idea, I've done some homework here.
I've looked back.
Well, let me just give you
my perspective on what you told me,
because we were gonna do
a retrospective episode,
and, you know, we actually,
over the summer, we did
the retrospective episode
of 2000 episodes of GMM, which
happened over the summer.
This is when we were like,
we're gonna do the same thing,
so we were trying to figure out other ways
to talk about this much GMM
without dipping back into
the same conversation.
Yeah.
It's a lot of conversation
about fan evolution
in that episode.
Right.
And...
So, we were talking like,
"Okay, we'll think about it over break."
And so then when we got back, you said,
"Well, I kinda went back to the beginning,
and started looking at
titles and thumbnails."
Just to jog my memory.
"And then I just went through all of them,
all 10 years worth of them."
And you were like-
Yeah.
And it took off, and made notes.
And you were like,
"And it took a lot longer
than I anticipated."
I was like, yeah, over two-thirds.
I mean, you could have, like.
I didn't realize that
I was signing myself in.
Ten episodes in,
you could've extrapolated
and done the math length.
Yeah.
And figured out how much
length this was gonna take.
I feel like I really, you know,
I owed it to us in reminiscing
and celebrating what we've done,
what we've gone through,
and what we've created, and what's evolved
on "Good Mythical Morning."
Oh, I'm glad you did it.
I'm glad you did it.
Over the years,
I just want-
You can call me and say,
"Could you start from the
end and meet in the middle?
You just let me worry about other things."
Well, it was just fascinating,
because, I mean, with 10 years,
at a certain point, the
show is just, it's a staple.
It's a part of our lives,
it's something that we go to the desk,
we enter that zone, and we, you know...
There's a rhythm to it that
it can kind of wash over you,
like, I'm a little
self-conscious when we talk about
"Good Mythical Morning,"
because I know that mythical beasts,
when you experience it as a viewer,
it's different than how we
experienced it creating it.
And we got to a point
where we don't go back and watch it
after the fact.
But also,
because we registered.
Many, many years ago,
we stopped doing that.
And I think you probably
have picked up on this
as we've talked about
the show over the years,
the moments don't register with us
in the same way that they
register with the audience.
Yeah.
Because...
I don't know.
It's kind of overwhelming for
us in that it's just like,
"What's the craziest
thing you've ever eaten?
What's the craziest thing
that ever happened on GM.
Do you remember when you did this?"
I was like,
when you point it out-
What's your favorite
episode? Yeah.
But like, when I'm gonna bed at night,
my mind is not filled with memories
of the crazy stuff that we do on the show.
It has to sort of be called out.
So I have a feeling that when
you go through these things,
I'm gonna be like, "Oh man, we did that?
Hell, we did that."
I wouldn't have thought about that again
if you didn't point it out.
And I was particularly fascinated
with how the show has evolved,
like remembering things
that we tried, you know?
Because we have this over simplified idea
of what the show has been
in certain, you know,
there's a Reddit post talking
about the certain eras
of "Good Mythical Morning,"
and I think that they presented
like five different eras.
If you go on Reddit and
just search GMM eras,
it'll come up.
But yeah, I ended up-
Don't search
GMM errors because that's
a different Reddit.
We don't want to get exposed in that way.
So, I think it would be fun
for me to go through episode,
like, what's the word I'm looking for?
Notable episodes, like,
so it's not the most memorable
or the most successful episodes,
but it's just notable episodes
along the way that said,
yeah,
that's part of the DNA of
"Good Mythical Morning,"
even if there's stuff
that we don't do anymore.
Okay.
And it might jog your
memory in other ways.
I'm also a bit tired this morning.
We had a little,
we had a party with a friend last night.
I stayed up past my bedtime.
Yeah, yeah.
11:30.
It ended at 11:30.
We caught up with
an old friend, the three of us,
and that rarely happens.
Well, and while we were together,
there was a point, I
believe it was 9:00 p.m.
when your phone-
Well, I was playing music
at the creative house.
We were playing music,
but your phone at 9:00 p.m.
began to play a Spotify playlist
that was unbelievably soothing.
And that we were like,
"Whoa, this is a mood change."
It's a hard turn.
And Link was like,
"This is my bedtime music."
And I'm not talking
about like sexual music,
I'm talking about sleepy time,
like make you go to sleep bedtime music.
Like meditation sleep music,
yeah.
Begins
for this man at 9:00 PM, and he's only 43.
When you're 73, you're gonna eat at 3:30.
You're gonna eat at 3:30,
and you're gonna go to bed at 5:00 p.m.
Well, there's something-
You're gonna go to bed
when the sun goes down.
There's so much
emphasis about sleep.
You know?
Like I said last night.
Our brains analyzing our entire sleep.
You're making the healthy choice.
I envy you in many ways.
I'm not proud of going to bed at 11.
I think I get adequate sleep,
but I think you get more sleep,
and I think it's probably,
you're gonna live longer because of it.
But apparently my sleep
is not of a quality.
Oh, yeah, I totally forgot about this.
Let's save this for another episode.
Let's analyze our sleep patterns.
Trust me, I've been
through a lot of episodes-
That's a good idea, that's a good idea.
My point was, you know,
we spent last night
reminiscing with an old friend,
and now it's like we're continuing that,
two old friends reminiscin'
about what we did.
Good segue.
January, 2012.
It's hard to believe.
Like, I mean, over the course
of the week of celebration
that we just did on
"Good Mythical Morning,"
a lot of special moments.
If you haven't seen all
those episodes, hey, go back.
It's like, we were surprised
by a number of those videos,
and it makes me super grateful
for what we've been through, but.
Could I?
One of the things I'm seeing right now is
I actually see a video
in December 13th, 2011.
Yeah.
That's called "You" on
"Good Mythical Morning,"
and it's us at our desks,
and it's a six minute video
where we are basically,
I think, fielding videos
for the wheel of myth,
for the...
Yeah.
Whatever we people say at
the, let's talk about that.
Then we were asking people to tell us,
let's talk about that.
So it was at least a month ahead of time
where you already let the audience know
that "Good Mythical Morning" was coming.
I haven't seen this video,
I've never thought about it
in 10 years, and here it is.
Is it unlisted, actually?
No.
It's not unlisted.
Hmm.
Is it?
No.
Because you're logged
in, that might happen.
But yeah, when we started this thing,
we've reacted on the society
to the first episode,
so I'm not gonna spend
too much time on that.
But like, the thing
that I noticed was that
my voice was still in a place where
I was kind of talking like this.
And I think it was because
we were restarting something,
I'd like to think that I
got into more of a rhythm
with good morning chia Lincoln,
that I was speaking a
little more confidently,
but I didn't-
Did you go back and see it?
I didn't have the heart
to go back and see,
but I will say very quickly,
as we were doing "Good
Mythical Morning," I changed.
So I got to a point where it's like,
you know what, I'm saying something,
and I'm speaking at volume.
But it was, you know, I'm
very self conscious of
what I felt like was a rough start for me.
Well, you know, we-
Better to have a rough
start than a great start,
and then fizzle out.
The reason that we both, at one point,
talked very quietly when we did podcasts,
it was because very first
podcast we ever did was
in this little office at the
Campus Crusade Headquarters
in Apex, North Carolina,
where we couldn't disturb
anyone else as we were talking,
and so we had to be very, very quiet.
And I think that maybe
that just stuck with you,
and you forgot that there
was no one around us,
like when we started doing
"Good Mythical Morning-"
Well, there's a difference
when you speak at this volume,
you're speaking to an audience,
versus you're speaking to one person.
And it's like, you know,
you're trying to find...
you're trying to find the right zone.
But you don't speak that...
I just wonder if you spoke
that way in regular life,
because you don't speak quietly now.
Yeah, that's what it is.
Different circumstances.
It's more of like, developing
an on-camera persona
behind that card table.
Right.
And I think getting, like I said,
we had done the Rhett and Link cast,
the live show for over a year,
then we did the Tea and Lincoln thing,
and, you know, I think it was
more of getting reacquainted,
but I'm glad that I
quickly got up to speed.
And then I'm also glad
that we introduced puppets.
Actually, that didn't
happen until season two.
So with season one, it was
like, we were doing best-evers.
We also went to Texas, and
we shot a couple of episodes.
You talk about talking quietly,
we did like 20 worst tattoos ever,
which that video performed really well.
We did it inside of a tattoo.
Yeah, when we were making the...
'cause we were still
making commercials for
local businesses still.
We went after Commercial Kings,
we went back to doing that.
What episode was that, what number?
108, "20 Worst Tattoos Ever."
We were both talking quietly,
'cause we were self-conscious.
Yeah, if you put me in a situation
where I feel like I might
be offending someone,
or making someone else feel uncomfortable,
that's when my personality changes.
And then we did take a
break, to our credit.
We took a summer break,
even after season one,
and we did that thing called
"Rhett and Link Vault,"
where we were like, "Hey,
we got some old videos.
Maybe you haven't seen them,
we're gonna contextualize them,
and then you're supposed to rewatch them."
We were thinking about taking breaks,
but still keeping content
coming over the summer.
I mean, that was a smart move to say,
"This is not gonna be
every single day forever,"
you know?
As we talked to other creators now,
we still very much say,
if there's a way for you to
set up how you work on things
so that you can look forward
to your own creative breaks
so you're not obligated
to keep churning stuff out
with no breaks, that's a smart move.
I'm glad that we did that.
And also,
at the time, if I'm
remembering this correctly,
we had not yet developed any sort of
block shooting schedule, which, you know,-
Oh, hell no.
We've revealed the secret about that,
about how we don't come in
and shoot every single day.
But at that time we were,
so you were coming in and
shooting every single day
at season one, so if
you didn't take a break,
there was no vacation.
There was nothing, you know?
And I definitely remember
there were times when it's like,
and we would sit down to do an episode,
and they were...
The concepts were very
loose, and it was like,
okay, I assume you're
gonna bring something,
I'm gonna bring something,
and we're gonna try to make this thing
land around 10 minutes, and
we're not gonna edit it.
So there's a push and
pull of creative tension
between the two of us of, okay,
I thought you were taken
over at this point,
I thought you were
bringing this perspective.
We had to work through that stuff-
And there's no saving
it with another camera,
or a jump cut.
I don't know when the first
jump cut in GMM history was
the first edit where something was hidden.
It didn't happen much, if
any, in the first season.
And I remember there were
times when it was like,
you know what?
I don't feel like doing this.
Let's just take a walk,
or let's not do it.
Let's get some lunch.
We'll shoot two in a row tomorrow.
Yeah, we never lost-
Or we would start it, and like,
one of us would be like, you know what?
We'd stop like five minutes
in and be like, yeah,
we're not to the thing that we said
we were actually gonna talk
about, let's start over,
Yeah, every once in a while.
And then they'd be this risk of it,
the other person reacting as
if they were being critiqued.
And the dynamic there,
it was touchy, right?
'Cause it was like, you
both have to bring your best
and feel confident, and you
got to feed off each other.
And if anything goes a little wrong,
I mean, we avoided as much as we could,
but there were definitely
times where it's like,
okay, abandon ship.
It's like, I can tell that
you're getting frustrated with me
because I've done something,
said something that just
rubbed you the wrong way,
or vice versa, you know?
I remember that.
It would happen, but it was pretty rare.
Well, Jason was there.
Without a third person there,
like, we would have been sunk,
because I think those moments
would have happened even more.
It's like, you tend to be
on a little better behavior.
But we were committed to the concept
of continuing the show.
Oh yeah.
So we would have figured it out,
but the other thing that we were doing
that I feel like is, you know...
what has gotten us to
this point in our career
is just this combination
of good fortune and timing,
and great help and some good instincts.
But one of the things
that we did as a choice
that I'm very happy that we made,
is that even though we didn't
have a production schedule,
per se,
what most of our peers
were doing at the time
is they didn't have regularly
scheduled programming, right?
So what happens is,
because you don't always
feel like making things.
And so when you're talking
about this scenario,
if we were doing this hand to mouth thing
where we were coming
in and we were filming,
and then we were posting when it was done,
which is pretty much what
everybody was doing at the time,
and pretty much what everybody
still does in a lot of ways.
Yeah.
A lot of people still do it.
It gives you this out.
Well, and then you're just like-
There's a fear of like,
if I commit to something,
and then-
But not only that,
if you don't feel like doing it,
you say, "Okay, guys,"
you go on Twitter and you say,
"Guys, the video is gonna be late,"
or, "So sorry, no video this week."
We've never done that in 10
years, that I can remember.
Yeah, that's right.
It's like, the season,
this is when the season is
is Monday through Friday.
There's been a couple of
times where an episode
either got pulled down for
some reason, or whatever,
and then we made another,
and put it on the society.
Or I actually saw early on in season one,
like a few episodes in there was that,
because of what was happening
with some internet legislation,
we did like a blackout,
and we didn't do an episode that day.
Yeah.
But I think because we didn't
give ourselves that out,
that's one of the reasons
that, 10 years later,
we're looking back at 21 seasons.
Yeah, season two, August of 2012,
that's when we introduced Time Rangerers.
I mean, we still have the puppets
sent by mythical beast in our likenesses,
and then, so that would
be within an episode,
but it wouldn't be,
we talk about something for a
little bit, and then we would-
But we put it in the thumbnail.
And there was no...
the scripting was
extremely loose for that,
and I just remember the,
you remember the catchphrase?
Give me a second.
I didn't watch any of these videos,
this has just come back to me
We would say it together.
Yeah, we were horrible at puppetaring.
It was our version of like
to infinity and beyond,
or something.
To the time machine, it was like,
something about the time machine.
To the gazebo.
The gazebo was
the time machine.
And I think Time Rangerers-
To the gazebo.
Might have just been a
mispronunciation of Time Rangers
in the first episode, I don't know.
Well, based on the thumbnails,
and the associated view counts,
puppets, not a strong choice.
We did "Best Ever Fridays."
Wow, people hate puppets.
People hate puppets.
Episode 37, "How to Make
Someone Sound Like an Idiot."
So this was an early
important episode for us,
because we talked about the Darwin Awards,
and so we talked about the thing that won,
and then we talked about another thing,
and then we talked about
the speech jammer device
that you could point it at
somebody, it's in the thumbnail,
but like we said, "Hey,
we can do this ourselves
using the delay within 'Garage Band.'"
And you listen to yourself
talking on a delay,
and you sound like an idiot,
and that was absolutely hilarious.
But we waited until, I don't know,
seven, eight minutes
into the episode.
When the episode was over.
Before we actually began demonstrating it,
because the first half of the episode
we were talking about
those inventions, right?
And like, the research side of things.
And we've told this story
at some point, I'm sure,
but a good friend and manager
of ours at the time was,
we were talking about that episode,
and he was like, "Hey,"
and this was actually like
a year after the fact.
Yeah, this was Dan.
We were talking about kind of making some,
like, we were evaluating GMM.
And he was like, you know.
Yes, like we said we
wanted to put sponsors in,
we had a slot for sponsors
from the beginning,
but we were like,
"Well, we need to be making
more money doing this thing."
So like, that's why we were having
these conversations with Dan.
And he said, "You know,
my favorite episode
is the speech jammer episode,
and I sent it to people,
but I always have to,
when I send it to people,
I say, 'Fast forward to
like seven or eight minutes
in when I started doing this.'"
Right.
And then it was like, well,
why don't we make the
episode about one thing?
Which was typically what we did,
but it was sort of a re-evaluation
of what we were doing.
It's like, if people are clicking on this
because of this expectation,
we want to deliver on that expectation,
and that was a pretty
significant mind shift for us.
Yeah, and I think there was
a little bit of fear in it,
'cause we would plan an
episode, we'd be like,
we gotta make sure that
we can fill the time.
What if, you know, in real time?
So we're gonna save
this thing that we know
is gonna be funny for a little bit later,
so that the episode is full.
We didn't have enough
confidence that like, okay,
you take one thing that
people want to click on,
and then you flesh it out.
It's like, no we've got to
throw other things in first
to make sure that we can break 10 minutes.
And once we made that shift and said,
no, you have a good concept,
you lead with it and you flesh it out,
that certainly helped
the product drastically.
I mean, one of the things I'm noticing
just looking at these old thumbnails
and the associated views is
there's an incredible
range of how low it can be
and how high it can be, right?
There's a psychopath smell test
where we're wearing blindfolds.
Episode 38.
Which has got 5.8 million
views from nine years ago.
And then there's the puppet
episode right next to it.
Well, over the years
people have gone back.
Right.
And cherry picked ones
that I think resonate more
with where the show ended up going.
I feel like I can actually
look at these thumbnails
without view counts,
and be pretty accurately predict
which ones performed well
now that 10 years of all this data
of how people respond to
titles and thumbnails.
it was just so experimental at the time.
And the feedback,
we're looking at 10 years
of collective feedback
on these videos, 9 or 10 years.
Yeah.
And so you see this
cumulative effect of like,
no one cares about
gladiators versus puppets
to the tune of 273,000 views
next to a 6 million view video.
And then we wrapped up
season two with episode 86,
which was a Christmas special, so-
Oh, yeah.
You know, even though it was
the first year of the show,
it was still a side
project in a lot of ways.
It was like, let's do something,
I mean, we're gonna take a holiday break,
let's do a special.
And we threw all this stuff at it,
Julian Smith was in that.
Yeah, 575,000 views, which
is pretty low for that time.
Which, again.
It was a lot of work.
How long is it?
28 minutes.
But-
It was special.
I think that the decision
to make that special,
and make it 28 minutes,
and make it a variety show
was what led directly to
"The Mythical Show".
You're exactly right.
That's why we decided to
do "The Mythical Show".
Until we were on our
own, we had done this,
and it was like, well,
if we can do it, we can do it
again, and people liked it.
I'm gonna put my phone on non-buzz.
Let's do an ad.
Non-buzz.
You know something else people like?
Getting stuff from our store.
We really appreciate that.
We have a lot of stuff over
at mythical.com for sale.
But it's a rotating
menagerie.
But it gets gone.
I mean, people like it,
they like the stuff that's happening.
Our team is creating
incredible merchandise,
and people are buying it.
It goes away.
And also, we like to keep it fresh.
I mean, this isn't like
your grandma's house
where you're gonna show up,
and she's gonna make exactly the same,
fried chicken or country-style steak.
We're not your grandma, right? Okay?
We've got things we don't change,
but the thing we do change
is we change the merch.
We love your grandma.
We know we could never be your grandma,
that's why we changed things up,
TBF.
But if you're like,
okay, I understand your philosophy,
but I don't want to miss out on anything.
Well, that's why we created
the last chance section.
Yeah.
It's your last chance to go get something
that's never gonna come back.
Yeah, and we put it in a section.
Tell your grandma about it.
So you can go there.
Season three.
Well, January, 2013, episode 13,
do you remember we tried
something called newsicals?
Yes.
Where we would take a story,
we had taken funny news stories,
like somebody getting arrested over, like,
complaining about their
fries at McDonald's,
and stuff like that,
and we would use those news
stories just for conversation.
But then we were like,
let's toy with the format.
Let's actually sing these things.
To some royalty-free music?
Sure.
It wasn't like, us playing guitar.
No, so it was a kind of operatic,
talky, singy-type thing.
Yeah, yeah.
It was fun,
everybody liked it, but
it didn't really work.
But it just goes to show you,
I mean, from an early point,
we were like, trying to develop formats.
Well, and again, when you look at,
okay, so episode 13,
"Pizza Thief: The Musical."
Just get a picture of you
holding a pizza and singing,
464,000 views.
The next day, episode 14,
"Nutella vs Peanut Butter Taste Test,"
1.8 million views.
Now again, at the time,
it wasn't like we were getting
this incredible feedback.
It wasn't like-
No.
You know, this is quite an
operation at this point.
We do AB testing on titles and thumbnails,
that's why they change
early in the day, you know?
And it's become much more of a science,
at the time, it was more of an art.
It was throwing things out
onto the internet, and also,
I would say a week after
that episode goes up,
we weren't learning like,
"Hey, people are loving than
the Nutella versus peanut
butter taste test."
This view discrepancy is
something that is registering
over the course of a decade,
not the course of us then making
decision about our content.
I mean, I will say six episodes later,
"Walmart Brand vs Name Brand Taste Test,"
and then episode 29, "Rhett
and Link Eat Insects,"
which still hasn't broken a million views,
which is interesting.
Which, in the "Walmart Brand
vs Brand Name Taste Test"
has got almost 7 million views,
which I, you know,
and again, we talk about this quite a bit,
but it just kind of illustrates this thing
that there's this...
What we don't do, what we try not to do
is just follow is just like,
oh, people like this,
and so that's the only
thing that we're gonna make.
So, we still have to do some
stuff that's just for us
and for the folks who've
been around forever.
Right.
So, I'm not saying
we wouldn't do another musical.
It's just now, 10 years
later there's this mentality
that like, okay, if we're
gonna do a musical episode,
we already know it's gonna be
a lot of work, a lot of fun.
It's gonna be very rewarding for us,
and the people who watch,
but it's not gonna make any money,
and no one's gonna watch it.
And you just have to be
like, "And that's okay,
and we're gonna go for it,"
you know?
Yeah.
That's what looking back on this is
sort of just a reminder of
the way this system works.
And you know, we were still
sharing personal stories.
I mean, our experiences
of getting acclimated
with living full-time in Los Angeles,
having moved across country,
our kids, our wives,
making the transition, we
would share funny stories.
But even over the course of season two,
that started to diminish more,
because-
We're running out of stuff.
'Cause we know that like,
our personal stories couldn't support
an entire show forever.
Yeah.
Right.
It's not like we're now
doing that on another show
that's even longer.
Episode 31, "Rhett and Link are Moving,"
episode 32, "New Studio Tour."
So by that point, the beginning
of season three in 2013
is when we moved into the new studio.
We knew at that point we were
making "The Mythical Show",
because that's what gave us the confidence
to start renting a space, and
the necessity to rent a space,
'cause we were hiring people.
Hired Stevie, we hired Ben, we hired Jen,
and we moved into that new studio,
episode 32, and we kept ma...
and then we had a makeshift,
they were building the set downstairs,
which ultimately became the
"Good Mythical Morning" set,
but it was built as
"The Mythical Show" set.
And then upstairs,
we would just set up the card
table, and working with Jason,
we would still make
"Good Mythical Morning"
while everybody that we were hiring
was working towards "The Mythical Show".
Was that the whole season
in that space,
was all of season three
in that upstairs space
at the old studio?
From episode 32 to episode 60.
So, and when we were
up there in that space,
our energy started to be diverted
into preparating for "The Mythical Show",
so it's like we couldn't
prepare as much for an episode.
So I remember telling Jason,
like this is a problem.
Episode 35, "Best Movie Theme Songs."
But instead of us alternating
and saying what we think are
the best movie theme songs,
we turned it into a game.
I'm not saying this is the
first game we ever played,
but it could have been,
but it was in this era that
we started to game-ify things
because it took the pressure
off of us to prepare a lot
when we had to devote that type of energy
to "The Mythical Show".
Yeah, that's a good point.
Episode 46, "Most Amazing
Optical Illusions"
got 22 million views,
but episode 55 and 56 were both games,
cartoon theme songs games,
greatest April fool's game,
you know, where one of
us will quiz the other,
or Jason would quiz both of us.
And it was, yeah, it was-
So games kind of came out of this-
It was an efficiency thing.
It was like,
yeah, again,
we're gonna digest all this information
and have to spit it back out,
or just perform and react.
But it wasn't that we were thinking,
"Games will be fun."
It was like, no, "We
need something that takes
the pressure off, games can do that."
It moves the prep, the
writing, if you will.
It kind of started to convince us,
because Jason was an editor,
and maybe he would have
done some research,
but we never allowed
ourselves to think that like,
we could ever hire writers.
But then you're like,
"Hey, Jason,
write this game."
We didn't think of
the show-
And all of the sudden,
we have a writer, we just didn't know it.
We didn't think of the show
as a show that needed writing,
because when we thought about writing,
we thought about scripted stuff.
Exactly.
In fact, that's still
often a misconception
when people find out
that there's writers for
"Good Mythical Morning,"
they interpret that as, "So
what you're saying is scripted?"
It's just, no, what we're doing,
what we're learning about,
the game that we're playing,
the question that was being asked,
that script.
Yeah,
the name of the game on the title screen.
There's so many details,
there's so much to be written
when you actually start thinking about it.
But yeah, as creators, it's like,
it's one thing to entrust
someone else to edit you,
that's a journey a lot of
creators get hung up on,
but then moving to a point
where you can get somebody
to write for you,
it's like, oh, you can
think of it differently.
It's not putting words in
somebody's mouth necessarily.
So all of that up into
episode 60 was leading
up to "The Mythical Show",
which was 12 episodes.
And even now, looking back
at "The Mythical Show,"
and very, haven't watched
it in a long time,
but I'm sure I'd be proud of it,
and I'd be very endeared by it.
And I'm sure there's a lot of things
embedded in these half hours
that we carried forward
creatively.
Oh, yeah.
We'd would have to sit
down and watch them all,
I'm sure people could that out.
But only 2 of the 12 to this day
have broken a million views.
Again, it's just the longer form thing
is not what were gone through.
10 of them,
and, you know,
that was YouTube giving us a
chunk of money to hire people
to make this show to
experiment with longer format.
And then, you know,
there's parallels between
that and when we did
the expanded version of GMM
that comes later, GMM 22,
that like, okay, even
though it didn't work,
there was an infusion of create,
like trying so many things
at such an increased rate,
and figuring out how to work with a team
that is growing in the
process is something that then
has ripple effects,
because we kept Stevie on.
And then it was like, okay,
we're going back to
"Good Mythical Morning,"
and it needs to be part of your focus,
"The Mythical Show", which
was your focus, is going away.
But I kinda, I remember the mindset
going into "The Mythical Show",
at least as I was thinking,
I was very excited about
"The Mythical Show",
and there was a big part
of me that was thinking
if this works, this could be what we do
instead of "Good Mythical Morning."
Oh, yeah.
Right?
Because again, I was more excited about-
There was no plan to go back
to "Good Mythical Morning"
that I can recall.
I was super excited
about this high level of,
there's so much creativity just put
into one particular episode,
and there's a music video,
and there's a sketch,
and then there's a game.
So it was a little bit of
everything that we could do,
but pretty early on, it
became clear that like, wow,
again, there's this weird
thing that the feedback
that we're getting,
and I'm not talking about
the quality of the feedback,
I'm talking about the
quantity of the feedback.
Like, some people who love what we do,
and love all the creativity are like,
so excited about something
like "The Mythical Show",
but you can't like, we couldn't have kept,
like we couldn't have, first of all,
YouTube wasn't gonna give
us any more money for that.
But even the money they
gave us to do that show
wasn't sustainable, like the
business would have just like,
completely gone under if we were like,
"Let's just keep making
that show with that money
that we're getting from YouTube."
Like, it wasn't a
sustainable business model,
but there was a little bit of this,
ah, man, we put this thing out there
that felt like it was
creatively innovative and oh,
okay, well I guess we'll go
back to talking to each other
at a desk every single day.
To me there was a little
bit of like, ah, really?
Okay, okay.
This is what you want from us?
You don't want us to do this
incredibly creative stuff?
But also the thing that
was happening, and listen,
I don't want to...
My mind has shifted a lot
over the years on this,
because I didn't appreciate
at this stage eight years ago.
I still had not accepted
the fact that this medium
was very different than traditional media
in that it was much more
about connecting with people.
And one of the things that
people were appreciating
was not that we could write a great song
or do something funny as a sketch,
it was that they're like,
"I like being with those guys,
and being a part of their friendship,
and seeing them crack each other
up, and seeing them laugh."
Yeah.
That was the experience
that was comforting people
and entertaining people.
And it's just a mind shift.
It doesn't mean that we don't
have all these creative aspirations,
it's just now we kind of understand
that there's a certain place for those
that's probably not gonna
be a half hour YouTube video
on our "Good Mythical Morning" channel.
But that was the first sort of like,
throwing this thing out there
thinking that maybe this
will change everything,
maybe we'll have the
first ever really popular
half-hour comedy show.
It'll be like "The Carol Burnett Show,"
but it'll be on YouTube,
and it'll go for 10 years.
No, that's not what happened.
So we went back in fall of 2013,
leading up to season four
of "Good Mythical Morning."
We made that weekend sucks ad, you know?
When "Good Mythical
Morning" is not around,
the weekend sucked.
Episode one, which is the
275th episode overall,
we were on the new set, we had altered
"The Mythical Show" set to be
the "Good Mythical Morning" set.
We started saying let's talk about that,
and we moved the fan
videos to be for the wheel,
spin the wheel.
That was all part of a
really focused evaluation
that involves Stevie, of like, okay,
we're changing the way we're producing it,
we're applying this team,
but that was also in Stevie began to,
she turned her attention
where she had not really been
involved at all creatively with GMM.
That after "The Mythical Show",
she turned her creative
instincts and producer instincts
onto GMM, and so the
three of us were sort of
attacking this thing.
And we had a few writers at the time.
Yeah, yeah,
and we kept our writers on board.
Actually,
that's not true.
We didn't have any writers yet besides...
I'm pretty sure we didn't,
because this was also when-
I don't remember
this time.
We started
Good Mythical More with season three,
but it was on our website.
So we were still doing,
we started at season three, but we had it
at RhettandLink.com.
Yep, we were trying to get
people to go to our website,
and that's the only way you could watch
"Good Mythical More."
Episode four was a spicy pepper challenge.
And Ben, Stevie,
and Jason and Jen all came on
during "Good Mythical More,"
and I was like, this is the
whole team bonding experience.
Where we impromptu brought them on camera
and made them eat the peppers.
Yeah.
And so it was just kinda
like something that happened,
and that's why I think that
was the extent of our team
at the beginning of season three.
Episode 27, "6 Legal Things
That Should Be Illegal."
So we were doing these
list episodes like, okay,
if Buzzfeed can do all
these click-baity stuff,
and there's all these click-baity
listicle titles out there
all over the internet, we're
basically capitalizing on that.
Yeah, and it was really working.
You got 8 million views
for six legal things
that should be illegal.
I just can't resist clicking on that.
It's like, no one gives
a shit about that now.
It's like, you know?
It's so-
Yeah.
But I mean, we learned that over time,
that's why those lists went away.
Everyone learned every list.
Yeah, it's like
they're tired of this.
Everyone was like,
"I've been through every list,
there's no more list."
Yeah, they were clicked baited so much,
there's only, you know,
I was burned one too many times
with a list that didn't come through.
And the thumbnail strategy at this point,
I'm noticing, with that episode,
it just has like a stock photo
of a woman sneezing into blackness.
That's a a good thumbnail.
What I don't see
is I don't see your face going.
No.
Or my face going.
I don't see that.
Yeah, it was like this.
I remember I would work closely
with Jason to figure out
some sort of eye-catching
Photoshop thing that was like,
okay, here's a sneeze.
There was a completely isolated,
self-contained strategy
for every single thumbnail,
as opposed to a thumbnail strategy,
which is-
That got exhausting.
That's a function of
what YouTube has changed.
We also started "Ear
Biscuits," episode 25.
We announced "Ear
Biscuits" on season four,
and we started doing Saturday
"Ear Biscuit" promos.
We'd put a video up on Saturday
where we would talk about
the "Ear Biscuit,"
because there was a video,
and we would tell a story.
But it wasn't a clip, it was
related to the "Ear Biscuit"
that you could go and listen to.
Yeah, so like we taught-
I forgot all about this.
Like, yeah.
In October we had Di Franco on the show,
and we were talking about that,
and he talked about a friend of his.
And so then on our Sunday episode,
we spend a few minutes talking
about Ben, back then in 2013,
you know what ended up
being an entire episode
that like is the most
viewed on the "Ear Biscuits"
YouTube channel.
Yeah, by a long shot.
Yeah, I just,
I totally forgot that we did that.
Episode 36 is when we did the hashtag war.
Remember hashtag war?
Still one of
my favorite things.
Hashtag GMM, we took it
from good morning Memphis
and good-
Good Morning, Maryland.
Two morning shows, like
two morning news shows
that were using the hashtag GMM,
and we basically did a
full on coordinated assault
to try to claim GMM for ourselves,
but it was obviously a publicity stunt.
And we did end up getting featured,
at least on Good Morning Memphis.
I think that good morning
Maryland at the time, like-
Somebody didn't follow through.
They were a little cold towards the idea.
We made some jingles for them,
but I don't-
I'm glad
you brought this up, because
I was actually thinking
about this this morning,
that there is a GMM out there
that is really popular now.
I told you a little bit about this.
It seems to be more popular than us.
You're talking about a new hashtag.
Yeah, if you just put GMM on Twitter.
Put GMM on Twitter.
Sounds like such a dad.
Look, GMM actresses.
There is a show,
GMM25Thailand is tweeting about this.
I don't know where this show is.
I don't know what country this show is in,
but it is incredibly popular,
and there's a huge cast of characters
that are on this GMM show.
And.
We have to do something about this.
I mean, I don't think we
can take the hashtag back,
but I feel like a collaboration
is at least in order.
Again, I have no idea what the show is.
I don't endorse it.
I don't know anything about it.
So just, let me be clear about that,
but I just assume it's-
It's not a band?
No, it's a show.
GMM actresses, it's a show.
I'm a hundred percent
sure that it's the show,
but there's all kinds of
people associated with it.
I mean, this is an after
party, a GMM after party.
We weren't there.
Oh, yeah.
It has nothing to do with us.
That must be fixed.
Like, we need to be involved with.
So here's a clip from the show right here.
I swear if GMM won't
give us another do to.
Oh.
I still blame time for
Ringoria, not in-game.
GMM got no manager to drive is it?
What?
I don't know.
We're gonna figure this out.
We'll figure that out.
In the meantime,
I'm gonna continue to my stroll
down memory lane.
If you know more about GMM,
the other GMM, and you're a fan,
#EarBiscuits.
Ironically, not #GMM.
Oh, so rounding out that fall of 2013,
episode 76, "Never Wet Our Pants."
17 Million views on "Never Wet Our Pants."
Yeah, episode 79, 13 million views
when we got waxed.
We got waxed.
So, I mean, we were starting
to get some momentum here,
season five, January of 2014.
That's when we moved "Good
Mythical More" to YouTube.
So the putting it on RhettandLink.com
was a short lived experience.
Yeah, that didn't last.
Episode 18, exotic meat taste test,
that's when we broke
a million subscribers.
Well, one of the things that I'm seeing
in the numbers here is that, season five.
So they're seeing like,
towards the end of season four,
okay, we're getting...
Some stuff is really taking off.
Some stuff is really getting traction.
Season five, so seven years ago.
Yeah.
That's when...
That has to be, based on
the numbers that I'm seeing,
that has to be the
beginning of what we called
the YouTube algorithm change
that we've benefited from,
where they started rewarding watch time.
Yeah.
Doesn't that sound about
like the beginning of that,
seven years ago?
So like, 2015?
Yeah, 'cause we got a million view,
a million subscribers around that time.
And then at the end of 2015,
we were about to break
10 million subscribers.
So for the next-
At the end of 2015?
Yeah, at the end of 2015,
so we went from 1 million.
So that was like the
course of a year, man.
How's that possible?
No, it was two years.
So for those two years, still that's the-
January, 2014, we had a million subs.
January 20...
Yeah, January of 2016 is when
we had 10 million subscribers.
So yeah, that's when it
really started to pick up.
I mean, I remember the
thing that I was thinking
at this time is that I had always seen GMM
as what I called the side project, right?
I mean, that's why we put
it on the second channel.
Yeah.
To this time, we're still doing like,
sketches, music videos,
and that kind of thing.
But...
This was the year that,
that two year period, 2014 to 2015,
it was where GMM surpassed in
anything that we were doing
on the Rhett and Link channel,
on the main channel in
terms of just the level
of engagement and the number,
at least the number of subscribers,
and just a fan base that
was building around it.
Yeah.
And I think both of us were thinking like,
oh man, this is becoming our thing.
This is not a side project.
Yeah, so a lot more focus,
so much so that we were like,
let's make a Hawkman
trailer for a Hawkman movie
that doesn't exist in hopes that like,
people will care about that.
They didn't really.
They did not.
Episode 82, "Will it Taco?"
Episode 88, sensory deprivation tank.
So it's like we, we had just
hatched the will it series,
and the sensory deprivation tank was,
so okay, we're gonna go out into the world
and do some stuff.
We didn't do it that often,
but it was a really good episode.
Well, before moving past "Will it Taco?"
It's got 20 million views now.
Was this the...
Up until this point I
don't know if we had done,
like the next time we did
will it after this was when,
because up to this point, we
didn't see things as series.
Yeah.
Right?
I don't see any evidence.
It was always like, kind of,
okay, maybe this is a slight twist
on something that we did,
or we're playing a game,
but we didn't have a title
that just changed out one word.
Like, "Will it Taco?"
Oh, now let's do, "Will
it Burrito?" or whatever.
And so that was Cinco de Mayo.
In July, we did "Will
it Ice Cream Sandwich?"
Which was in the next season six.
Okay, so it took us a full
season to come back to...
That's interesting.
Again, we weren't seeing, like-
It took us two months, yeah.
But we weren't...
And we're just way
different these days where
we're constantly trying
to come up with an idea
that then can be a series,
because we just found that
that's what people like.
I mean, obviously there's
production considerations for that.
You get something that works,
you want to do it again
because the team knows
how to produce that,
but also it develops a life of it's own,
like the international dart
game has, at this point,
which I'm sure you'll talk about
the first time we did that,
eventually.
But we weren't thinking
about the show in that way,
at this time.
Yeah, at the end,
over the course of season five,
the other thing we did
was wheel of mythicality animations,
we started releasing those.
And then season six, July of 2014,
that's when we got our
new intro with the column
where it starts at night, and like,
it's going up the column.
We still had some more
animations coming out.
Episode nine of season
six, that's when we did the
vacay gone cray-cay.
Cray-cay.
Cray-cray,
where we would re-enact stories
of people's vacations gone wrong,
which was sponsored by the
same people that sponsored
"I'm on Vacation," the music video.
Post someone at a hotel?
Choice hotels?
Yeah.
But yeah,
in that episode nine,
it was also on a Thursday,
that's when we would also do mail.
So we started having variety episodes
where we would do a little something,
usually a prompt from a fan,
and then we would go into the
Vacay Gone Cray-Cray segment,
because we wanted to be
able to sell to a sponsor
a segment within an episode,
but then do other things that we could use
to market the episode
with title and thumbnail,
and we would add mail to it.
And then, so Jen would bring out the mail,
but she wasn't on camera, and
it was in the main episode.
She wasn't on camera?
She wasn't on camera.
And we did sing the song.
Yeah, Thursday means mail.
And you're talking season six?
Yeah.
Episode nine?
Episode nine.
Episode 17-
Okay, because we still called that,
"Outrageous Camping Gear You Must Own."
And yeah, because the first
thing we talked about was-
Which got 5.6 million views.
Outrageous camping gear.
Again, the lists were working for us.
No one was gonna click
on watch us re-enact
somebodies bad vacation,
but once we got the click
with the crazy looking tents.
So we were figuring out those things.
It's like, if we can do a
variety episode every week,
we can learn more,
we can do more creative things,
and we can connect with
the mythical beasts
by reading their mail.
Episodes 17 is when we
went to the YouTube space,
and we had Daniel Radcliffe on the show.
Up until this point,
we really hadn't had guests on the show.
We had had guests appear
on "The Mythical Show,"
but then we didn't add any
guests when we went back
to "Good Mythical Morning,"
but we couldn't turn
down Daniel Radcliffe,
and I just remember being
so freaking nervous.
Like, I still can't.
I wouldn't watch that episode back.
Well, it's not only that,
we wanted it to,
first of all, we had this hang up,
and we still do have it
where we were like, okay,
when a celebrity comes
to the YouTube space,
and other YouTubers go to it,
it's almost like a press junket,
and they're just do making videos.
For us, it felt a little cheap, right?
Because we were like,
"Man, we want our show
to feel like a place that
celebrities want to come
and actually be on,
because that's what a legitimate show is."
Jimmy Fallon doesn't go and go somewhere,
you come to his show.
That had never happened,
but we said that's how we
would want it to happen.
But the compromise was, we're
going to print out our set.
No, Paisley actually built it.
He built it like.
Oh, yeah.
Paper mache,
it was like-
Yes.
Paper mosaic.
It was really amazing what he did,
and I don't even think
it came across on camera,
but your eyes forget that
we're not in front of our
own set.
Yeah,
so we did basically a portable set,
which was a whole lot of work.
Later when we had to do the
same thing another time,
we printed it out.
But yeah, I forgot the
first one was a literal.
He unrolled the thing.
It was crazy.
It unrolled.
Yeah, it's crazy.
And then we had to sit around for hours
for Daniel Radcliffe to show up.
And he was a joy.
He was a joy.
Episode 56.
That was the Carolina Reaper.
That's still the thing that
is more often than anything
the thing that people
talk about if they see us
out on the street.
Episode 110 was our first weirdest E-bay,
where Stevie was-
Oh, really?
The host.
Well, okay, so Stevie,
yeah.
Wrapping up
2014.
At what point
did Stevie start becoming
the voice of the goddess
off camera?
I don't know.
'Cause I know that
season four, episode 64,
we did the movie setting game,
which was the first time that we had...
We're like, let's put
a title screen on this.
We still didn't say, "It's time for,"
but we called it something impromptu,
and like Jason made a title screen.
Jason was the off-screen
voice for those games,
so I don't know exactly
when that switched,
but by this point, Stevie was not only,
she did that on camera what
was doing stuff off camera,
I'm sure, by that point.
So then let's go to season seven.
All right.
January 2015, we had a
new wheel with 24 spaces.
That was a big moment.
Yeah.
We would have variety episodes that were,
they were so question-based,
so I remember that we would take questions
from mythical beast
and we would use those,
the writers would then
pitch us comedy bits to do.
Like someone gave feedback on how I was,
like, we took a comment about
how I made Eddie eat something
that he didn't want to eat,
and I was kind of being a jerk to him.
And so they were like, you were like,
yeah, it actually happens a lot,
and we cut to a sketch
of hidden camera footage
of me being a tyrant around the studio.
So we were still trying to
all different types of things
in like these many variety
episodes.
It got 5 million views,
or it does at this point.
'Cause we called it "Link Is A Tyrant."
We also started "Song Biscuits."
So this was a new thing.
It was like, all right,
not just doing an "Ear Biscuit,"
and having them come on the show.
But that was a weekend series.
Yeah, but we got...
I mean, that was ambitious.
That was kind of a,
"Hey, you're gonna come on a podcast,
and then you're gonna
write a song with us."
I wouldn't have said yes to that.
We made it easy for people, man.
They didn't have to do much.
Yeah, but,
I was like, man, that was
asking a lot of people.
But, okay.
Yeah, and like you said before that,
there was the wheel of
mythicality animations again.
So, I'm thinking about
where this decision leads.
That's one of the
fascinating things for me
is that we make a decision
for whatever reason we
were making it at the time,
and then just making the decision
then leads to something else.
So I would say that decisions like this
to do song biscuits on the weekend...
Okay, maybe what we
were thinking, I dunno,
one of the things we
were thinking was man,
like we've gotten to this point
where we're putting so much time
into "Good Mythical Morning."
It doesn't really justify
itself to put all this time
into a music video on our main channel,
unless it's sponsored.
And even then sometimes it
would be weeks or months of work
for one piece of content, right?
Whereas we can do as well with GMM.
So we were like, okay,
well we're still really
good at writing songs.
Let's make it something
that's more interactive,
and quicker, and that's what
led to doing Song Biscuits,
and hey, why didn't we put that
on the Rhett and Link channel?
Well, again, at this point in season seven
there's all this traction
on "Good Mythical Morning,"
so it's like, this is the place
that people's eyeballs are,
so let's put it on the weekend,
on the GMM channel.
That decision led to things
like mythical kitchen, right?
Because mythical kitchen,
before it was mythical
kitchen, it was a weekend show,
you know, where Josh would
make something on the weekend,
and I don't know how long that went.
Yeah, I can get into some of that,
but yeah, for this,
and it was also we're trying to promote
this podcast through-
Yeah, right.
Our channel that's-
'Cause it was still guest-based.
"Ear Biscuits" was
guest based at the time.
2015, we go into the
fall for season eight.
We were done with "Song Biscuits,"
and we started them releasing
the animated versions
of those as a music video.
We used to do that.
The backup plan continued.
We did the cereal bowl
bath on episode five.
We really weren't having a lot of guests,
but episode 55 was when we
had Shay Mitchell come on,
because...
there was some sort of
connection that like,
she actually wanted to come on our show,
and I had to eat, I ate a live beetle.
I'm not proud of that.
And we had, episode 45
we had Smosh on the show.
Yes, so we started to-
Ian and Anthony, at the time.
I think we had them on "Ear Biscuits,"
and that was like a cross-promotion
instead of doing a song biscuit,
'cause I guess we were done with those.
It's like, maybe we can double up.
We had already gone to
"Pirates vs. Ninjas"
for debatarama.
Yeah, that-
That was the beginning of
the end for the debates,
if I recall correctly.
Didn't work that well.
Episode 91, we did "Will it Pie?"
which is the only will it on location.
Yeah, out in front of the pie hole.
Nobody really cared that...
It was interesting, but it
wasn't anything to continue.
It didn't add anything.
No, it didn't add anything.
So then-
Which I think
is an important point to register,
because it's just like, oh,
well this episode required
traveling to a place,
setting up, and it's like,
oh, this will be cool.
Breath of fresh air, literally,
but also makes the show feel
like it could go anywhere.
And you're like, oh, it didn't
translate into anything else.
We could have just been at the desk.
Let's just be at the desk.
January of 2016, season nine.
That's when we got that new desert intro,
and it was my new haircut.
2016.
Wow, it's been that long.
It's been that long.
Will it's we're still the biggest thing,
but we were doing games, we
were doing ranking stuff,
we were still doing lists.
Episode 43, "Can You Hear Colors?"
So we're doing experiments.
I mean, we were trying
a bunch of different
taste test stuff, like the
flavored oxygen taste test,
physical challenges.
Like, we were doing these weird,
like we would invent our
own physical challenges,
and that, like magnetized
mullets, magnified mazes,
like all these weird physical challenges.
That didn't last too long.
But episode 62, I think is still
our most viewed video ever,
"Game Show Cheaters."
"Amazing Game Show Cheaters."
Which was just an anomaly.
That thing blew up way after the fact.
Something happened with the YouTube system
that kept sending this
video as a suggested video.
You can see where the views came from,
and it was always a suggested video
that was popping up for people.
And people want to click on that.
And they just like,
we always have-
Cheater during
the showcase showdown.
Yeah, we put a arrow at the cheater.
We had an extras channel
that we were doing
"Good Mythical Crew," but
then we moved that show,
"Good Mythical Crew" to Saturdays
where we would have like,
Mike or Alex or Chase, like
showing them how they would,
what now is behind the mythicality
on the mythical society, basically,
is something that we started in 2016,
starting to feature the crew,
and show behind the scenes content.
But also there was, you've sort of skipped
over the middle thing,
because that was, again,
it was a Saturday launch
for something that then
became it's own channel for a
certain amount of time.
Well,
there was an extra
channel, and then we were,
it wasn't called this is mythical yet,
and we were moving some,
so that was the main thing,
the good medical crew.
Right, yeah.
This is when we broke
10 million subscribers,
and had our 900th episode.
Episode 105, "Will It Burger?"
That was the first mythical
chef Josh appearance.
This is when we broke 10 million,
because earlier you
said we broke 10 million
at the end of 2015.
Yeah, it was episode 70,
so at the beginning of 2016.
Okay.
So it was still like,
basically two years.
I saw a picture
two years ago.
Two years,
almost two years exactly.
So then Josh showed up,
but then he went away
again for like a while.
He only helped us in that one episode.
And then episode 120,
that's when we announced
"Buddy System" season one.
So like all of this stuff
was happening back then,
around this time, season
9, going into season 10.
Season 10...
episode 54, we released "Buddy System,"
we did the conjoined twin challenge,
and we celebrated the 1000th episode.
We also did, it looks like our first ever
retrospective episodes
around the holidays.
Right.
Very different thumbnail strategy,
like top 10 Link gags,
ridiculous Rhett reactions,
Rhett and Link can't stop laughing.
They were shorter, but this
was sort of the precursor
to what we do now, which is
like the top five moments.
Yeah, we ended that right before
we did those retrospectives,
we released episode 102,
which was the international
Christmas food.
So we were throwing darts at the end of
2016.
So the very,
very beginning, the
first time we did that,
we were already throwing darts.
All right,
so now we're in January,
2017 for season 11.
This is when we had mythical channel,
throwing things over there,
but we were still doing the
good medical crew episodes,
I think on Saturday, on GMM.
But we weren't having guests
unless we had a connection to them,
like Myam on "What's on
My Head?" for episode 33.
I was the human nacho in episode 65,
episode 69.
That became a thing.
Yeah, that became a thing.
Discontinued snack taste test,
started back then in episode 69.
And then after around episode 83
is when we announced
"Buddy System" season two,
and that's when we started
doing good mythical summer
for the first time.
Yeah, so a couple of things
were happening there.
So with buddy system going
into season two, at this point,
again, we were putting it on
the Good Mythical Morning channel.
Even though we didn't want to.
And that was just because, by that time,
again, there was so much focus on GMM,
and it's so difficult to like,
keep this level of content up,
and also make a scripted
show, do the podcast,
do the weekend series that it was like,
okay, there's not a lot
happening on the main channel.
Now we just call it
Rhett and Link channel,
'cause it's definitely
not the main channel.
So yeah, it was like,
this is a little bit
weird to put this on GMM,
but it probably will get more views.
I don't know if that was true,
if it would've gotten more views
if we put it on the
Rhett and Link channel.
We had to announce it during this season
so we could explain why we were
doing good mythical summer,
and we were having guest hosts.
It's like, "Why are you guys going away?
What is it you're doing?"
So we would start teasing it,
but then it wasn't until
season 12, that fall,
when it actually started coming out.
A lot of things happened in season 12.
I mean, we had our new
stop motion animation,
episode three was our brosectomies.
Oh, wow.
We released our "Book of Mythicality"
in episode 37, and
announced a tour for that.
Episode 44, it was our first
leaving things in Coke.
Episode 52 was our last episode
before we switched over to GMM 22
in the middle of the season.
Wow, so there was so much
stuff happening at this point.
I'm thinking about,
I'm trying to like think
beyond just what was,
there's so much happening
with "Good Mythical Morning."
Yeah,
It was now, I mean,
just getting vasectomies would
have been enough for that.
Now, one thing I will say by
season 12, which was what year?
2017.
So 2017, like if you go in the back end,
and you look at the engagement
and the views and all that stuff.
So again, there was this
sort of incredible time
of like 2014, 2015, 2016,
like this three-year period
in which there was this
incredible amount of views
and incredible amount of audience growth.
Like you said, like breaking
10 million subscribers.
2017 sort of represented
a little bit of a slow,
things were beginning to slow down.
Now this wasn't-
I would say level out.
You know?
Yeah, yeah.
Well, the growth was the
growth was slowing down.
Like, this explosive
And then if you just look at the numbers,
what you won't see is
you won't see an episode
that has 12, 15, 18, 20 million views
like some of those ones
that had broken out
during that time.
Now, again, that's not a
function of a strategy change
on our part, it's just
a function of the change
of audience tastes and
also the YouTube platform.
So we're kind of like, okay,
this is maybe the new normal for where
this thing's just shaking out.
In the meantime, doing
all this other stuff,
like you mentioned the
book, the tour, the show,
and then YouTube knocks
on our door and says,
"Hey, do you want to," they actually said,
"Do you want to do a good mythical night,
or good mythical evening?
Like a daily nightly show in
addition to your daily show?"
We were like, "Do you?
I mean, there's only two of us.
We have a lot of help,
but there's still only
to see these two guys."
That turned into well,
let's apply those changes
to "Good Mythical Morning"
itself, and hence GMM 22.
We call it 22 because it was, you know,
a half hour of television is actually
just 22 minutes of content.
So we were trying to make four videos
that totaled up to roughly 22
minutes of content, because-
There was a little bit of potential hope,
and actually, this was discussed is,
would maybe that show in its entirety
end up on linear television at some point,
like there was a discussion about that.
It was crazy that that was a discussion,
but that was a discussion.
Most of the discussions were
about click the green border.
Yeah, oh yeah.
We're not gonna talk
negatively about GMM 22.
We've done enough of that.
I'll present the positive sides of it.
You know, this was the first,
like we accelerated how big our team was,
how big our set was.
There was an injection of creativity that,
where we had to make all
these different videos.
We had to make four videos
a day instead of one.
So we were willing to
try things and say, okay,
one of these or two of these segments
are gonna be the things you expect,
and they're gonna perform well.
Like episode 59, freezing our bodies.
This is gonna work,
we're gonna go to a
cryogenic therapy place.
Then we're gonna come back to the set
and do Big Mac versus Whopper,
and that's gonna perform really well,
and then we're gonna do
this silly invention thing
where we wear sauna
pants, which we just made,
and then we're gonna do
this very quick thing
called censored kissing game,
which the writers, we really
had to push the writers
to come up with comedy bits that then
where we can play fun games,
or quick improv type things.
So we were reapplying
our efforts and lessons
from way back with this
is "The Mythical Show",
which was a half hour and saying,
well, you know, we're not
gonna make a 30 minute video,
we're gonna make each of
these internet videos,
and then there's room for experimentation.
And because of that, we did learn a lot,
but we had to do things like
we have to have a teleprompter.
This was the beginning of that.
This is when we started
having a teleprompter
instead of like,
trying to commit stuff to
memory for just a few seconds,
and then say it in twice as
much time as it needs to take,
and declare it with a lot more prep
than we have time to give to it.
And to clarify, okay,
so when we talk about what's scripted
and what's not scripted on
"Good Mythical Morning,"
so for a very, very long time,
maybe not from the very beginning,
but definitely their early seasons,
what we had scripted was, okay,
at the beginning of this thing,
when the camera turns on and
we say good mythical morning,
the things that we're going
to say right at the top
are essentially scripted.
It started loose, and it was like, okay,
I've got a little thing I'm gonna say,
and then you're like,
okay, here's how I'm gonna react to it.
Then it slowly evolved
to a place where it was,
I think literally written down,
and you would look at it and be like,
okay, I think I could say that.
Again, this is just the intro,
just like the first
minute or so of the show,
'cause we wanted to
quickly and efficiently
get into the good stuff, and
set it up in the right way,
orient people, maybe there
were rules or whatever.
So yeah, so that was the existing system.
And then, but what would happen sometimes
is we would have this sheet of paper,
and we'd be trying to get it,
and we'd go through 2,
3, 4 takes sometimes
just getting the takeoff of the show done.
Which is very frustrating.
And it's taking a bunch of time,
and I think, all along...
I can't remember who it
was if it was Stevie,
or whoever it was was like,
what about a teleprompter?
We were very anti-teleprompter
because if you know
what it looks like when somebody
is reading a teleprompter,
you know what it looks like when somebody
right?
Yeah.
And then that makes the
show feel less authentic.
And plus, we were self-conscious about it,
but we basically knew
we had to figure it out.
We had to utilize it
for the show openings,
and so it was just one of
those things that made GMM 22
feel off at the beginning.
It wasn't just about the fact
that it was the wrong color,
and that we're using different cameras.
There was a lot of
transitions that shouldn't
have impacted the audience
experience that did,
because there were so many
things that we were changing
in our experience behind the scenes.
So like, using a teleprompter,
and the specifics of how we were using it.
But that ended up being a good thing,
it's like forcing us to
figure out what are our terms
for using this tool.
We learned when not to use it,
'cause I think we overdid
it in certain times.
Yeah.
And we also
got better at, you know,
if you want to look and
you want to follow our eyes
and get really specific
you, I mean, you probably,
if you watched a show enough,
you know when it's happening,
but we got better at it.
So somebody who's coming into
the show for the first time
doesn't feel like,
"I'm walking into this
stiff newscaster situation."
We also had writers
writing more comedy bits
that we were figuring out, is this for us?
Are we...
Do we want, do we enjoy this?
Are we good at it?
Can we take someone else's
joke and say it as our own?
There was a lot of...
or work within an improv
bit where it's like,
we're gonna be sucking
helium and saying...
and then ranting about things that are,
again, on a teleprompter.
And a lot of things didn't work,
but-
Yeah.
It was great to have to force ourselves
to try these things,
and at least have these segments that were
like our bread and butter and
that we knew were gonna work.
We also had guests come in,
we had a dedicated effort to book guests
like through traditional means, like...
A booking agent.
That's how you get "Weird Al" Yankovic
to come on the show.
That's how you get in
touch with Jack Black
to come on and sing "Silent
Night" for episode 85.
We also, at the end of
that year, episode 84,
we made the "Christmas Booty" music video.
Decided to re-engage then.
All we had done was announced
buddy system season two,
none of it came out until
season 13, January of 2018.
We reduced our number of videos
from four to three per episode,
but we were continuing to
do the segmented GMM 22.
At the end of 2017,
it was during this season
that we were releasing
"Buddy System" season two.
It was all happening at the same time.
Yeah, it's also when I
started gonna therapy.
Yeah, that was freaking crazy.
Well, you know,
there's a couple of other elements too,
that this is not the kind of thing
that we typically think
about or talk about,
but I'm sure that if we were to talk
to some of the folks who work more
on the production side of GMM,
a lot of the things that we do now
in terms of the way
thumbnails are created,
the way that graphics are created,
the way the editing
workflow, the audio workflow,
all this back-end stuff
that enables the show
to happen every single day,
those efficiencies were
developed during GMM 22.
That's not something that
we often think about,
but anything that worked, we kept.
What didn't work, which
namely was doing three or four
or five videos every single day
didn't work on a number of levels,
but there's so many things
that we took forward.
Yeah, we learn how to work with guests,
and so then, well,
I won't get ahead of myself,
because that's the second half
of GMM 22 in January, 2018.
That's episode 12 is when we
did fancy fast food, big Mac.
So it's like, that is a staple
of the mythical kitchen channel now.
We did our first munch madness tournament,
which we ultimately...
That was pretty pivotal.
Yeah.
Was it a multi-day thing?
Oh yeah.
And then episode 116, "Will It Churro?"
was the last GMM 22,
but then the things we
continued from there were
having guests on the show,
being able to use the
teleprompter for the stuff that
we just needed to get through,
like how a game works.
Right.
And the intros.
So it was, there was, like you said,
there was a lot of efficiencies that like,
when we said okay, in season 14,
we're going back to one video a day,
and then good mythical
more, and that's it.
And it'll
forever be that way.
We now have this capability.
We were like, wait, if we
can make three or four times
this amount of content in an episode,
then we can shoot things more efficiently.
We can start shooting
more episodes in a day.
We can have more time
to work on other things,
and still keep "Good Mythical Morning,"
at the caliber we had.
'Cause one of the things
that was happening with
the book and the tour
and "Buddy System,"
which represented things
that we really want to do,
they become more difficult to enjoy
when you just can't really
devote time to them, right?
And then everything begins to feel
a little bit like a burden, like, okay,
GMM, when you want to work on this,
GMM feels like, oh, that
feels like a burden.
Or it's like when you've
got GMM scheduled to shoot,
and, "Well, I need to work on this book,"
that begins to feel like a burden.
Yeah.
We knew that wasn't sustainable,
we also knew the thing
that we didn't want to do
was stop doing anything.
Right?
That's the one thing that
we've never really considered
is stopping doing anything.
Right.
It's just finding a more
efficient way to do it.
But the beautiful thing about this is that
it solved a lot of problems
for us, but then nobody,
like, I mean, I'm sure
there's somebody out there
who's like, "I was disappointed
when you guys went back
to one episode a day."
I know that that group of
people exist, and you know what,
I love you for that.
But I think the vast
majority of people were happy
to get their good old
traditional GMM back,
but we were able to be like,
"Hey, we can actually write
this thing or do this thing."
"Oh, no, we didn't do a
buddy system season three,
and we probably never will, but hey,
we're trying to do other things."
And we wouldn't be able to do those
if we hadn't transitioned back.
Season 14, episode 13 is
when we did shuffleboard.
So, you know we had confidence
to do these bigger set
pieces, like shuffleboard.
Also that's when we
released the GMM billboards
with the body paint.
Well, and another thing that
is beginning to happen here
pretty consistently, I
would say that it started,
it started during season,
it started a little bit during the GMM 22,
and then it settles into
itself a little bit more
in season 14 is there's
a thumbnail strategy.
There is a face, might be
your face, might be my face,
filling about half the screen,
there's words on the thumbnail
itself, like big bold words.
That's happening more
and more often, right?
And we had it, yep.
And then we had a long
streak of high performers
from episode 29 to episode
36, MRE taste tests,
six and a half million,
leaving things in nail polish,
six and a half million, president foods.
You remember Jordan was talking for the-
Now we're bringing the,
I think we're trying to
bring that format back.
Yeah.
And this was the season
that we launched LTAT.
So GMM 22 went away, and
then LTAT, we started that.
Let's keep going into season 15.
Okay.
I mean, this is start getting quicker,
'cause they're getting closer to things
that are just new news.
January, 2019,
we had that new collagey intro,
and we were like, we're doing
the Rhett and Link live shows
that we started in London.
Right.
So it was like the concert.
Yeah, we got hypnotized.
Yeah, you talked about
Finland doesn't exist.
Like, what's my superhero mask?
Like episode 91 was "Hot
Food Cold Vs Cold Food Hot."
It's like getting into
some of those things
that we're still doing now
in 2019.
Well,
by the time season 15 rolled around,
we were definitely getting this
very clear message that was,
"Hey, when you guys eat weird stuff,
or when you guys just eat stuff,
or when you guys talk about food,
it's gonna get more views."
And so the game began,
or became finding ways
to incorporate food into an episode
while it's still doing
something completely original
that doesn't feel derivative.
It's still the name of
the game in a lot of ways,
but, as you can see, we continue to,
and as we continue to
continue to try to find things
that aren't eating food that
people will get excited about.
Yeah.
And you know, it's like
once you get into 2019
where you got 16 million subscribers,
we're talking about the
lost causes of bleak creek,
we've got Josh doing a
show on Sundays after LTAT,
we're launching alternate
universe snacks with wheat fix.
And then we did the buoys
creek series, episode 1,630.
And then by the end of that year
we had done our bleak creek mini tour,
and that was when we wrapped up LTAT.
And then we're all the
way to season 17, 2020.
Oh, dang.
Launching gut-check, eating
every Ben and Jerry's flavor,
not knowing that COVID's
right around the corner.
So then we had the home
split-screen episodes,
then like slowly ramping
up our ability to produce
back in the studio to the
point where by episode 1789,
we've got this huge putt putt course,
talking about the most
expensive item at 7/11.
Yeah, so just in bringing us closer to,
bringing us to last year.
Yeah, it's funny as
I think about-
And present.
You know, okay going from GMM 22,
well, again, you think about the era's,
and the early GMM of figuring
a bunch of stuff out,
then that early middle
era that we talked about
with the incredible growth
and the incredible engagement.
Yeah, the takeoff.
And then the thing that I think
I wouldn't have been able to process is,
'cause you could believe,
like if you could think,
and I think maybe some people
do think this is just like,
"Oh, you guys, you really screwed up
when you did the GMM 22 thing,
and that's why their videos aren't getting
20 million views," or whatever.
But looking at what actually happened
is there's this incredible growth,
and then things sort of settled
into a place just because
that's just what YouTube works,
there's changes that take place.
And we kind of settled into something,
and then when we did GMM 22,
the views actually were, and
the engagement sort of went up
just because there were so many videos,
but we abandoned that for all the reasons
that we've covered, and those things,
and if the efficiencies-
It wasn't refining,
then it moved into a refining phase,
which that Reddit thread
called a Renaissance,
where it was, yeah, it
was a reinvigoration
of what we do best,
and doubling down on
those things, you know?
So you might start to
get more homogeneity,
but to capitalize on the success,
and that was really working
in that Renaissance phase.
You know, this is the thing
that we are always up against,
and I'd like to spend a little bit of time
just talking about the future of GMM,
like what are the next 10 years of GMM,
if that's, you know, I don't know how long
we're gonna do the show,
but let's just say that
as we move into the second
decade of GMM.
Yeah.
One of the things that you definitely see,
and of course, listen,
we are very in touch
with what longtime mythical beasts think,
and all the opinions that float around,
and we value all that.
We're making this show for you.
You know, we are also frustrated
by some of the changes that
have taken place on YouTube
to reward that homogeneity,
is that the word?
Of a product and a predictability,
and things that have led us to, yeah,
the thumbnails pretty much feel the same,
because whenever we divert from that,
we get less clicks, right?
And that's something that, you know,
you look at the most engaging
YouTuber on the platform
and Mr. Beast and look at his thumbnails,
well, he's doing the same thing,
and he's doing something different,
but he's doing it in the same way.
He knows that that
that's the system, right?
He's not doing the old strategy,
which is constantly trying something new.
He's like, "This is what works,
I'm gonna keep doing it
for as long as I can."
Yeah.
It's interesting when
you're making a video that's
a show that's coming
out five times a week,
and we're getting this feedback
that this is what people are clicking on.
Obviously they continue to click on things
that are food related, but...
we don't just do this
show to just fill a gap
in our business strategy, right?
Every day we think about
"Good Mythical Morning"
as this is still our bread and butter.
Yeah, we want to do other things.
We are doing other things,
but this is still our bread and butter.
This is still something
that people depend on
in a lot of ways, and enjoy.
It's not just some fluffy product
that we want people to just, you know?
It's meaningful in people's lives.
It's meaningful in our lives.
But the thing that we've
been talking about recently
is as we find ourselves in this platform
where consistency and
predictability and homogeneity
are rewarded, right?
The more you can kind of center
on a strategy on a channel
and be like, this is
the very specific thing
that you're getting from this channel,
and this is the very specific
thing that you're getting
from this channel.
We've had this sort of existential crisis
that we've been dealing with, which is,
well, we're trying to do a variety show.
We're trying to do a show that
comes out every single day,
and covers a lot of different ground,
but we're doing it in a
place where specificity
and focus has been rewarded more and more.
You know, when people try a
bunch of different things,
they're not necessarily getting rewarded.
They tried a bunch of...
we were actually, we
were watching some TikTok
videos last night, as a matter of fact.
I'm talking about this
phenomenon on TikTok
where you can look at
somebody's channel and be like,
oh, this is this guy.
And he was trying,
he's doing like seven
different characters.
And all of a sudden, something
clicked with one character,
and then he finds him as that character.
Now, every single video is that guy.
And my question was,
are we moving into a place on the internet
when it comes to internet content
where everyone just zeros
in on the particular thing
that is working, and then it's like,
you've got this,
forgive the analogy,
you've got this cow that's got udders,
and then you're like,
"Oh, everything's coming out of this teat.
Let's just focus on this teat."
And you just, and this is
what the internet does.
The internet sends you
to a particular teat,
and you keep going back to that teat.
Sucks the life out of a teat,
and people suck that teat clean off.
And what we are committed to doing,
both as a company, as a brand,
with our whole suite of content
and everything we're doing,
and including GMM is we want you to suck
on every teat, you know?
We don't want to just suck, we
don't want to just give you,
we don't want to just keep
putting one teat out there
for you to suck on.
It sounds embarrassing,
but I have to agree.
We've got lots of teats,
and we want you to suck on
all of them to equal degrees.
I think there's a focus-
When I think about the future,
I'm just thinking about
continuing to make sure the udder
has got lots of teats, and
it's not just a one teat.
We have a loyal viewership
of mythical beasts
that are gonna watch no matter what.
And what we're realizing is that
this presents an opportunity for us
and the team to say,
"Okay, we are gonna determine
to continue to experiment
to assert that we are
more than just people
who shove food in our face."
Yeah.
And we need to take risks creatively,
and we need to try different
things, and continue the story.
You know, there's ebbs and flows.
There's like, okay, we tried this thing,
and then it, maybe you say
the whole thing didn't work.
It's like, that's not true.
There's always things that carry
on from everything you try.
Yeah.
And yeah, even the things
that don't work lead,
they help direct you into the future.
So, if you know we're gonna
run interference on this,
but I think that's where
we're at with GMM is saying,
okay, how does it continue
to evolve, you know?
And how do we earmark a certain
number of episodes where
we're gonna continue to push
innovation and experimentation
within the parameters of us being able to
show up and do it within
the construct of the show.
Yeah, and this has been, you know,
frankly, with the pandemic...
we've had a great, great
time during the pandemic
as a company.
Our team has been incredible
being able to produce the show
that we've been able to produce.
It's just phenomenal what
we've been able to do,
but it's been tough.
It's been tough on our team,
it's been tough on our writers,
especially who are isolated, you know,
it's like we have a
production crew that comes in,
but it's still less than what
we had pre-pandemic, right?
And we don't just bring in
all the writers all the time,
because it's just unnecessary
risk at this point,
but believe that we're getting towards
the end of this thing,
and we're gonna get back to
whatever our new normal is.
One of the things that,
I'm just saying this
because there's a level of
excitement around the show.
Yeah.
And I think that as we think about
not having the restrictions of a pandemic,
getting our crew back
here in this building,
not yet, as soon as it's safe.
I mean, not talking about everybody back,
and really doubling down.
I'm just saying this to
say that when I think
about the future of GMM,
even already this year, like me and you
have been thinking about it
and been engaging with it in a way that
because we do so many
other creative things,
and we have such a great team,
there are times where I kind of like,
I don't really have to
think about GMM right now.
I can just show up and
be a part of the episodes
in the way that I am, but I
don't have to think about...
the future of it and like,
where are we going with this?
But right now there's this focus on,
this is something special,
and it's not gonna just fade off slowly
and be this thing that is
just a relic of the internet.
Like the focus right now
is like, hey, you know,
this is incredible that we've
been doing this for a decade
and there's been ups
and there's been downs.
We've learned a whole lot,
but we're not just trying to settle
into a comfortable thing.
Like, we're still trying to innovate.
We still will innovate.
We're gonna be trying newer,
bolder things this year than
we did last year, you know?
We've never been more focused on that.
And the appreciation that
I have with this process
that I went through of looking
back through all of this
is that like, it's a
continuation of what we've done.
It's like the reason why the
show has gone on so long,
and will continue to go on,
is that it's constantly changing.
It's never just one thing.
It's most usually changes are not drastic,
but they're over the course,
you know, you discover things,
you realize we discovered things,
and then you apply those things,
and so that's gonna continue to happen.
So I don't anticipate a drastic change
in "Good Mythical Morning,"
but I fully expect a continued
evolution of the show,
and I do sense that we're at a juncture
where over the course of
this year, it's going to,
as we spend our time looking
backwards over 10 years,
we've done our celebration, and now it's,
all right, we're continuing
to push forward, creatively,
and so that we can define what the show
is gonna look like 10 years from now.
Yeah.
Over time.
And like you said, you know,
and this is actually one of
the things that's given us
this sort of, I think,
a newfound sense of...
We tend to, like lots of
people in this business,
and lots of people in
entertainment in general,
and probably just lots of
people around the world,
sometimes you begin to
let a little too much fear
creep into the way that you
think about things, right?
Yeah.
So I think when you've been
doing something like this
for as long as we have,
and you've kind of experienced
the level of success
that we have, and you've
seen ups and downs,
anytime there's a down, fear creeps in.
It's like, oh, well, okay,
what?
And then fear doesn't lead to innovation.
A lot of times, a lot of times
for people fear leads
to taking less risks.
You get scared and you're like,
"I don't want to go,
I don't want to go into the deep end.
I don't want to try that."
And we kind of recognize
that, and of course,
we've had the restrictions
of the pandemic,
which restricted the ability
to really innovate in big ways.
But because we have that,
I don't know what the number
of people specifically is,
but there are a number
of you out there who,
like Link said, you
watch every single day,
like you're just a GMM watcher.
It's part of your daily routine,
or maybe you watch it all on Saturday,
but through the ups and
downs and the changes,
you've watched the show.
And you actually give us
the ability to take risks,
because what we found is,
regardless of what we do,
there's a certain number
of people who are like,
"Hey, I'm showing up.
This is what I do.
I support you guys."
Knowing that and embracing
that has really given us
this confidence to be like,
man, you really can't,
we've got nothing to lose by
really getting experimental.
Yeah, it's a great place to be in
to have 10 years under our belt,
and to know that we've
got that loyal connection
with those mythical beasts,
and it's extremely comforting,
and it makes this exciting.
And you know what?
As much as we talk about clicks and views,
and the reason we talk
and think about that
is because we're trying
to support a business here
with a lot of staff.
But when we think about GMM,
I think I speak for both
of us when I say this,
when we think about GMM,
and we think about what we're doing,
and we think about the
person that we're talking to,
I'm not thinking about that person
who just clicks on a video
every once in a while.
I'm thinking about the person who,
I'm thinking about a mythical beasts.
Yeah.
I'm thinking about a mythical beast
who is coming back, you know?
And when we continue a dumb bit,
I don't re-explain the bit
like this is your first time,
I just take it for granted
that this bit is for you
who've been watching, you know?
And if you are watching
for the first time,
well, you'll catch up,
you'll catch on, you know?
It's like stepping into a game
after everybody started playing it.
You'll figure it out.
I think I anticipated
that I would be a lot more
sentimental at celebrating
10 years of GMM.
Well why don't you cry?
I think the reason why is
because it's not over, you know?
We're already looking forward,
and I don't think we've ever
stopped looking forward.
So yeah, it's nice to
look back and celebrate
on GMM over this past week, to do that,
and it has been special,
but having this overwhelming sense of,
I'm not gonna say we're
just getting started,
because that's cheesy.
We're not.
We've done this for 10 years.
Actually, we're saying that
at the beginning of every
episode this season.
We're just getting to started,
but you know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
It ain't over.
So...
I'm not prone to get too
sentimental about something that
I'm in the middle of
and very excited about,
and as we look forward.
So, I'll just leave it at that, no tears.
Yeah, I mean, if the
show ends at some point,
which for whatever reason it will,
I mean, there's gonna
be some circumstances
that lead to it ending at
some point, I'll cry then.
Shit-right.
Shit.
You shit-right, man.
Okay.
I got a quick rec.
I've been listening to the audible version
of the book "Will,"
Will Smith's autobiography.
Oh, that's cool.
Seen the cover.
You know, being a huge fan of...
Like, being our age,
like growing up and experiencing
like the DJ Jazzy Jeff
and the "Fresh Prince"
era as a middle schooler,
and really loving music documentaries.
Like, I loved the first third of his,
book because it was about that.
And so if you're my age
and you're into that stuff,
you'll be into hearing the stories behind
the making of everything that
led to those first two albums.
And then the stories of him,
the story of him getting to be
"The Fresh Prince of Bel-Air."
There's some shorter
stories out there on YouTube
that are absolutely amazing,
but hearing him perform his book,
he doesn't just read his
book, he performs his book.
Like, he does impressions of every single,
of so many people, and
you can tell it's like,
these are like his grandma,
and Jeff, and Quincy Jones.
And so it's really great stories.
And then, I got to say,
I wasn't a huge fan of
Will Smith, the actor,
I was just, you know,
more of the musician,
and "Fresh Prince,"
but I actually couldn't
have told you that, like,
yeah, he was pretty much, for a long time,
the biggest star on the planet, like-
Yeah,
It seems very obvious, but like,
I wasn't a fan of his movies,
but then seeing that, and like,
so as a business owner and leader,
I enjoyed the second half of
the book in terms of like,
him saying, okay, as an artist,
this is what I'm going after,
and this is the team I'm
surrounding myself with,
and this is how we're gonna go about it.
And there's also the
partner aspect of like,
you know, being a husband, being a dad,
like all that stuff
was pretty cool too.
It's pretty inspiring.
A lot of fun to listen to,
some really good stories in there.
So if that floats your boat,
I highly recommend.
"Will."
"Will," the Audible book.
Well, thanks for joining us.
Thanks for joining us for 10
years, if you're one of those.
Here's to 10 more.
Yeah.
Hashtag "Ear Biscuits."
To watch more "Ear Biscuits,"
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of "Ear Biscuits,"
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.